hey guys it's max in this video we're
gonna be comparing my own surface laptop
3 which I really like against Apple's
new 2020 13-inch MacBook Pro we're not
only going to talk about things like the
keyboards trackpads displays performance
but other things such as fan noise
thermal throttling and more let's start
out with the exteriors I'm gonna go
ahead and close these laptops up and
show you that the MacBook Pro is more
compact it's a little bit less wide and
less tall and even though it is smaller
it is actually denser it's about 3.1
pounds compared to 2.8 pounds now both
of these are made out of aluminum the
MacBook Pro is a little bit more solid
and a little bit thicker but they're
both nice with the surface you do have
the Microsoft Surface connector for
charging and if you want to use
proprietary docks and other accessories
and then on the other side here the
surface has a standard USB a port full
10 gigabit per second speeds and a USB
type-c port but it is not a Thunderbolt
port whereas the base macbook pro has to
thin about 3 ports and the higher-end
one has a 4 so you can expand much more
with the macbook the surface uses a
wedge shape meaning it's thinner than a
mac on one end and thicker on the other
because of that extra thickness
microsoft was able to put in Windows
hello camera you guys saw how quick that
was it recognized me and you just hit
Enter or space and bam it logs you in
the surface doesn't have a fingerprint
scanner like the MacBook Pro does which
has a touch ID to log in now let's talk
about the keyboards the surface has a
nice keyboard with 1.3 millimeters of
travel the keys are fairly clicky they
feel really nice with the new 2020
MacBook Pro Apple has its new magic
keyboard that has one mil of travel it
has a little bit more feedback when
you're clicking it feels a little bit
more mechanical so I do prefer apples
looking a bit lower let's talk about
track pads the surface uses a diving
board design but it is above average for
a Windows laptop definitely usable
whereas the MacBook Pro uses Apple's
force touch technology where there's
actually magnets in there meaning you
have a perfectly even click anywhere on
the trackpad and you can adjust it as
well so apples is better there are two
more difference
wanna mention the first is the speaker
grills on the MacBook Pro we have up
firing speakers and the surface you
don't see a grill but there's two nice
speakers hid underneath the keyboard
that are going to surprise you in just a
bit when we compare them the other
difference is the touch bar a lot of
people don't like it on the MacBook Pros
some people do the shortcuts will change
depending on which application you have
open and the surface doesn't have one of
those now let's talk about the displays
and for once in the last couple months
the MacBook Pro actually has slimmer
bezels than its competition the surface
has a thirteen and a half inch screen
and it's a three by two aspect ratio
screen compared to 16 by 10 meaning it
is slightly taller and just a bit more
square and Microsoft's still stuck with
fairly large bezels that aspect ratio is
nice when surfing the web working on
documents but you do have a little bit
larger black bars if you're watching
video now as far as detail both of these
displays have just over four million
pixels
they're both nice and sharp but the
surface doesn't have anti reflectivity
coatings that are anywhere near as good
as the MacBook Pro you guys can see
right here this one's almost like a
mirror compared to the MacBook Pro which
has very little reflections what makes
matters worse is that the display also
doesn't get as bright it gets up to
about 400 nits compared to 500 nits on
the MacBook Pro so the MacBook Pro is a
lot easier to use outdoors or in bright
rooms the MacBook Pro can also display
more colors if you guys look at this
little logo right here on the surface
it's all one solid color whereas the
MacBook Pro you see the circle and the
little icon on the inside that's because
it can display dcpip three colors so
about 25% more colors then the surface
now the one area where the surface beats
out the macro pro's display is off axis
viewing so it stays a lot brighter if
you're watching from the side and then
of course you do have a little bit more
vertical space for documents and now
let's compare the speakers go ahead and
put on your best pair of headphones
[Music]
so as far as speakers the surface laptop
three is definitely louder about two
decibels on average and the high notes
are a little bit sharper as well but we
are comparing it to the base 13-inch
MacBook Pro and the higher-end $1,800
one actually has improved speakers so
let's go ahead and toss this one up
against the surface
let me know your thoughts down in the
comments section below and I'll give you
guys my opinion one thing that I love
about the surface is how loud those
speakers are but when we compare it to
the higher-end MacBook Pro it's
interesting because it's still louder
when we had those vocals but as soon as
the bass kicks in it actually lowers its
volume down to prevent from distorting
and at that point the macro stays
consistent and it's dedicated woofers
provide a lot more bass and then the
mids are actually richer so if you're
going to be comparing the high spec
models of these the macro is better but
on the low end the surface is definitely
better than that $1300 MacBook Pro both
of these laptops use 720p webcams and
here they are side-by-side for you guys
to compare the quality of the video and
also the quality of the microphones the
surface actually has microphones right
next to the webcam so let me know down
below which one looks better and then
which one sounds better as well and now
let's talk about performance I'm going
to go ahead and run Geekbench 5s CPU
test over here now this is where things
get a little bit weird for 2020 the
beasts 13 inch still has hn processors
whereas the surface has tension but with
that said when we look at the actual
performance the surface does beat it out
but by only about 13 and 15 percent
which is still good now these are the
base models with the i5 quad cores if
you spend more money the macro code does
also get tension CPU but it is an i-5
whereas the surface has a tension I 7 so
comparing those the surface is still
faster the Mac actually does give you a
nice of an option cost another $200 and
it's still slightly slower than the
surface and because of that we wouldn't
recommend that extra 200 bucks it's not
that different now we're gonna talk
about full CPU load in just a bit but
first let's talk about the graphics I'm
gonna go ahead and get this OpenCL test
started and since the surface has
Intel's tenth generation chips they
actually have the option to have the g7
graphics and they did even on the base
model you have the best graphics
compared to the MacBook Pros older 8th
gen
ethics and as you can see the surface
laptop threes graphics are about 40%
more powerful now if you do get the
higher in MacBook Pros you can get the
same g7 graphics but that costs a lot
more where Microsoft is offering this
performance at this base price and now
let's compare the SSDs both of these
models have 256 gigs of SSD but the
surface you can actually swap out that
module it does use a small little SSD
and I'll go ahead and link one down
below for about 130 bucks you can get a
512 gigas d which is nice
and now comparing the speeds here it's
very interesting both aren't ultra fast
but the macro pro's right speed is more
than twice as fast as the surface I'm
guessing the higher in configurations
might be a little bit faster but for 256
the MacBook Pro is definitely faster now
another thing that the surface laptop 3
gets is Wi-Fi 6 and in my house I
upgraded my router and in the toughest
corner of my house with the MacBook I
only get about 90 megabytes per second
compared to about 170 with the surface
of course if you have an older router
it's not gonna make a difference or if
you're close to the router but in those
scenarios it is nice and with the
MacBook Pro even the highest end one
with tension you still don't get Wi-Fi 6
announced compared fans and thermal
performance
I'm gonna run cinnamon jar 20 which is
gonna max out the CPUs and we're gonna
see how these guys perform surprisingly
when the surface is plugged in it's
actually pulling 3738 watts compared to
25 so it's using more wattage which is
great but it's also or heating up faster
the fans are kicking up sooner so I'm
hearing noise here but because of that
in the wattage dropping we're now only
78 degrees Celsius compared to 95 on the
MacBook Pro we're about halfway done now
the Mac is starting to spin up its fans
but it's running at 96 degrees Celsius
compared to just 79 on the surface both
are using 25 watts and running at about
2.7 2.8 gigahertz we're almost at the
end now the macro cooled down to 91
degrees Celsius because of fans kicked
up and it's quite a bit louder than the
surface and also because the clock
speeds are running at 2.9 gigahertz
compared to settling in at 2.4 gigahertz
on this
and we have our results the surface is
about 10% faster not only that it also
ran about 10 degrees cooler and the fans
were quite a bit quieter now if we were
testing the higher-end models then we
would have an i5 tension compared to an
i7 tension but both would get roughly
nineteen hundred points because apples
i5 is a little bit faster with the clock
speeds but I do suspect that the surface
would still run cooler and quieter and
now for our verdict if we're taking a
look at these lower end models the
MacBook Pro definitely has a nicer
display brighter less reflective better
trackpad but the surface performs a lot
better in terms of CPU beacon in terms
of graphics because of 10th jen has
louder speakers and you can actually buy
the surface a lower end model that has
128 gigs of SSD for just 999 dollars and
keep in mind for a hundred thirty bucks
you can pop in a 512 gig SSD and that
makes it such a great value at the lower
price points because of the performance
that you're getting
unfortunately screen is reflective but
that's about it now
if you're looking at the higher-end
models then the MacBook Pro starts to
become a better value because for the
price point you're actually it gets cost
you less for the i5 spec without similar
performance and the same size SSD and
you're getting four Thunderbolt three
ports where the surface is just stuck
with one USB type-c port and of course
we do have OS differences with the
MacBook Pro yet Mac OS which a lot of
people like so if you're looking for the
higher-end models
I think the MacBook Pro is definitely a
better buy but for that low end the
surface really packs a really good punch
I'm gonna have links where you can get
the best deals on both of these down in
the video description below
let me know your guys's thoughts in the
comments section and click above to
subscribe if you guys want to see
another great video we have a couple of
right over there there's been max max
tech and I'll see you in the next video
[Music]